picture and he joins us tonight miss
Rama thanks coming up thank you for
having me so we just showed on the
screen the photograph of former
President Barack Obama before he was
president with Louis Farrakhan you took
that picture where was it it was in the
Congressional Black Caucus meeting room
actually I was looking at the picture
and if you look very very closely you
can see on some of them people they have
a sticker this is hc9 which is the one
of those caucus rooms in the basement of
the yes of the Capitol where meetings
are held and that's where it was
taking place so why have we never seen
this picture before well a couple of
things I was sort of honorbound
immediately the day of the picture that
was taken I was on Capitol Hill I worked
out of the Senate radio TV gallery at
the time a staff member from the black
caucus called me and said we have to
have the picture back and I was kind of
taken aback and and it's like you know
so we talked a couple of times on the
phone after that and I said okay well
I'll give the picture to Minister
Farrakhan chief of staff who was Leonard
for Archon Mohammed he's shown on the
far left of the picture and I gave the
original disc to him and in a sense
swore myself to secrecy because I had
quietly made a copy for myself just it's
my picture it's my art it's my
intellectual property I you know I
wanted it I owned it and I wanted to
keep it and so it wasn't my place to but
why would people from the commercial
black caucus or the Nation of Islam
headquarters in Chicago not want that
picture to come out well I don't think
it was so much the Nation of Islam but
rather the black caucus perhaps they
sensed the future this was 2005 now
there were no he had just been in the
office a few months but the idea and in
fact he had people from the Nation of
Islam working on his staff in his office
in Chicago Senate staff the members of
the Nation of Islam helped him in this
Senate campaign on the south side of
Chicago so but I think as people
considered the ambitions the thought was
minister
Farrakhan and his reputation would hurt
someone trying to win acceptance in the
broad right cross section did he have
contact with anyone from the Nation of
Islam as a senator or as president that
you know of nothing I know of I he he
did have as I know as I recall there was
a member of the Nation of Islam in
Chicago worked on his staff on his
office in Chicago his constituent
services office in Chicago but I never
knew her I never knew her name but at
some point in his to thought you know at
some point she was no longer on his
staff I don't think it was a acrimonious
departure but she just was honest to
have anymore so what was Louis Farrakhan
remembers in Asia Islam were they
offended that President Obama wanted to
distance himself from them some were
many were many were angry
many were hurt that not only did senator
Obama denounced Minister Farrakhan he
rejected him in the same interview
appearing I forgotten what was with
Senator Hilton that Senator Clinton yes
and she went after him about well I
rejected the support of some people that
she considered unacceptable
in New York when she was running for
Senate and really demanded that he do
the same and so he said okay if I'm
satisfied I'll reject him too and so
people in the nation have a sensitivity
about this and feel that we've often
been made Minister Farrakhan has
certainly been a litmus test for people
whether it was fair or not because
people who want that acceptability in
the crossover you rights they can't
stand the Inquisition that comes with
being associated with Minister for I
wish does it come out earlier because I
think it makes for an interesting
conversation wherever you fall along the
spectrum thank you for coming on tonight
miss Ron thanks for having me on the
picture and telling us what it's about